on parle
place spéciale le mont péko tout est
entré en éruption
son habileté explosivité et de huit
secondes à des proches en brousse tente
pour exploser les unes après les autres
une explosion nucléaire peut diminuer la
pression de la chambre
[Musique]
vous êtes en train de me dire que vous
comptez faire sauter une bombe nucléaire
la frontière chinoise
de pittem chaud quand vous aurez les
têtes nucléaires rejoignez le site que
doit avoir une explosion séparation de
la tête nucléaire
j'ai lancé le compte à rebours
je te donne rendez-vous en affaires
le volcan est entré en éruption
gouvernement ne cautionnera pas cette
vision
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
moi j'arrive pas à y croire